Hello believe nation
I started the mentor me series to try to spend a little bit more time with people who've done a lot more than us and
by
Watching their videos listen to them speak
hopefully some of their mindset their values the way of thinking their
Execution rubs off on to us to help us become better versions of ourselves
So today we're going to learn from former Indian president. Epj Abdul Kalam and some of his
Inspirational speeches as you watch the videos if he says something that really inspires you or means something to you
Make sure to put it in the comments below and put quotes around it so that others can be inspired as well
Having you an instant this is all of you who are assembled here all of you remember this incident
Slv-3
Satellite launch vehicle. I were the project director mission director
My mission is to put the satellite in the orbit
Thousands of people work nearly 10 years. I
Reach the I reach the Surrey arakata
Condition the launchpad counter was going on
t-minus four minutes
t-minus five minutes
t-minus one one minute t-minus 40 seconds
Computer put a hold don't launch it
Computer says don't launch it. I am the mission director. I have to take decision
Everything is on
Behind me. There are six experts they saw
Did a computer database coming in and screen and they see the pictures of the screen?
They said there's a problem. The problem is there's a leakage in a system in the control system, but
immediately calculation no problem
we have got sufficient fuel and oxidiser country control system is contours a rocket to the record attitude and
We can go ahead now
Of course my experts view, but I took a decision
Problems mine, right finally. I took a decision. I bypass the computer I launch the system
inaudible event
First state you worked in a four stage rocket and second stage got mad. It went to the spinning
Instead of putting the satellite in the orbit it put in the way of the gun
1979 it was a failure. It was a failed first time. I experienced my failure. How'd he manage the failure success I can manage
So at that time be a great man, you're a great leader. Also Satish Dhawan
He comes to me I have very tired working nearly four months it wakes me up come let us go for a press conference
Prosperous meeting there like this number of people world, press before all this and that all the gadget they are there
I was really frightened. I will be the culprit because behind the project that equation directly
What's at least our said chairman Indian speciality or consent dear friends? We have failed in it
He is the first time I
Have to do all the success
All the failure is I want to support my technologists and scientists and staff
So that next year they succeed
So he took the whole blame himself
and then
Media asked you put way of when got so many crores you are putting like that a lot of criticism
He received a criticism. He assured them in a year will succeed with our team is a very good team
next year
Here only interesting. They happened next year, July 18 1980
when he succeeded
But also now and said you go and conduct the press conference. Do you follow with what it means?
It means when the failure occurred the leader took it up when the success came he gives to his team
you should stand for a culture of excellence the
Reaction is not by accident
It is a process where an individual
Continuously strives to better oneself
The performance standards are set by themselves
They work on their dreams
with focus and
are prepared to take calculated risk and
Do not get deterred by failures as they work towards their dreams
Then this step of their dreams
As they tend to reach the original targets
They strive to work to their potential
In the process they increase their performance
there by multiplying further their potential
This is an onion ting
lifecycle phenomena culture of excellence they are not in competition with
genuine arts but themselves
That is a culture of excellence. I'm sure each one of you
Will aspire to become a unique with culture of excellence
So there was a break-in cyclist. You are travelling from London 1930
by ship to
Calcutta
when he reached the Calcutta angular that evenly around 6 o clock the Sun was setting
At that time you looked at this time first blue and she was blue the
Horizon was blue, but she sea water was blue. He asked a positive voice. She's blue
Why?
Why horizons blue sky is blue. Of course. She has to work for two years
hard work in Calcutta
Then he got a Nobel Prize for that because it was a back scattering of light
Can you think of a person?
Such severe Amon got the Nobel Prize for that scattering of the light
Now we have DCT very close to the city
Created a very famous mathematician at that time
As a British India and
The British India could not
Locate him because he failed the nth n plus 1 ten plus two in those two
He currently intermediate in every subject except mathematics. He could not further go for higher education, but
She's education something beyond his bright
Genius he was a genius
and
Somebody you have British fall or located this genius in port officer in Madras
And his papers are being sent to
Royal Society and professor Harding sudden his paper
Then he waited in me behemoth one of the greatest mathematician of them security
So this is he was Ramanujan so friends there is another great, but greatly
She's the worry ladies. Got two Nobel Prize
one for radium discovering another for a physics suffer material
this lady is
Madame Curie and
She lived for the radiation
she sacrificed life irradiation by
Furman because radiation therapy is she tried on that and so friends all these people see eight names. Are you you
Call this eight names
When I Delta Y event what they are self without an immediately when I say that
the name of the person you can relate the
Reaction your foot one of him
Thomas Alva Edison immediately said bulb and electricity
Alexander Graham Bell Telephone
Immediately. You said telephone telephone. I said Alexandra travel
Backscatter infinite immediately sir, such you round
Radius radium immediately you can say miracle. So all these people they are unique people is it not
Because they are unique you are remembering
So so far we have studied those who walk into unexplored paths
And strive to be a unique under remembered for their contribution to the human type
remember period French inventions and discoveries
Have emanated from creativeminds
that are being constantly working and
Making the outcome in the mind
With the imaging and constantly effort all the forces of the universe
Word for that despite mind
thereby
Leading to invention discoveries. I
learned
But carefully hear me. What is he I
Learned. What did I learn from the youth of 11 million people? I
learnt the ovary youth
Wants to be unique every youth wants to be unique. That is you
The over you taught to be unique that is you but the world around around you is doing it test
They might you just need everybody else
No
Questioning whether you want to be you are everybody else
you
You want to be you?
Not your every else
now
If the first being like everybody else is convenient
At the first glance but not satisfying in the long vision
the challenge there for
my young friends is that
You have to fight the hardest battle you have to fight the hardest battle
Which any human being can never imagine to fight?
and never stop fighting until you arrive at your
Destiny of you they've got to get Negrete you
It's a big battle the battlements
You don't need to take a garden the battle means you have your food unique things
For unique tools. You must have that battle
One is you have to set the goal?
The second one is acquired the knowledge continuously and third one
It's a hard work with the ocean and fourties perseverance you gives up the tools
You have the other before the battle the way you do these as we say in India
Where there is righteousness in the heart where there is righteousness to the heart, there is beauty in the character
When there is beauty in the character
There is harmony in the home
When there is harmony in the home
There is harmony where there is an order in the nation when there is order in the nation there is peace in the world
Mr. President Abdul Kalam
in the name of the European Parliament, I
Want to thank you for this important and inspiring speech
This was one of the most extraordinary speeches we have ever heard
From a statesman
Scientists and poet. This is unique
All the best to this great nation
India all the best to our cooperation between the great nation India and the European Union all the best
Mr. President
Thank you guys so much for watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to know which of the points resonated most with you
What are you going to change in your life or your business as a result of watching this video?
Leave it in the comments below and I will join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout out to Evans Sargent. I love your name Evan by the way Evan. Thank you so much
You're buying a copy of my book. It really means a lot to me those you're watching
you want to change that a shadow in a future video make sure to
Pick up a copy of the book and email in your receipts so we can keep track
Thank you guys so much for watching continue to believe or whatever your one where it is, and I'll see you soon